dude college what is college college is
long it's expensive and for the most
part it's pretty boring so we do a lot
of weird and clever things to get by and
it's these weird and clever things that
make college that much more entertaining
the main difference between high school
and college is the way you learn is up
to you you can voice record a lecture
and play it back later at a faster speed
allowing you to focus on more important
things in class
you smell exquisite students on average
spent one thousand two hundred and
twenty-five bucks on school supplies
last year that's over a hundred games of
laser tag
but there's something quite amazing
about not having much money it forces
one to get creative coffee need other
ways to save money try selling your
books back at the beginning of the next
semester
they'll be in higher demand you can take
a spring from a pen and wrap it around
the end of your computer cord to protect
it from getting broken do you have any
idea how expensive those things are
according to one study huh 61 point 4
percent of students live off campus you
have more roommates now and that means
together you share more resources protip
put two TVs in the living room one for
videogames and one for your soaps a
recent report found that over five
percent of students do not have their
own internet don't become a statistic
people make sure you pick a password
everyone remembers mine is I forgot it
never fails and make sure you have high
speed because pretty soon
hot emic muscles is gonna want to come
over and study the only thing in this
apartment you'll want to be slow
is your germs ecology weird it's a time
for you to say yes to everything be
spontaneous and stay clever
it'll make college way more entertaining